the final season of Game of Thrones is
coming bringing eight seasons of
conflict politics and mystery to an end
but how does Game of Thrones begin what
is the first episode reveal about the
story Episode one begins with men of the
Nights Watch attacked by White Walkers
an ancient threat thought to be long
dead we get a glimpse of a Walker's face
and their design changes a lot
throughout the series but they still
look very different to the walkers in
the books who are more ghostly and
elegant the walkers leave wildling
corpses in a strange shape and we see
the same shape six seasons later in
carvings made by the children of the
forest because the children created the
White Walkers in a ritual with this
spiral shape which the walkers also
imitate the walkers copy the symbols of
their creators but why maybe it's a
warning because the walkers don't kill
all these Watchmen they seem to let will
go showing him a severed head then
letting him run south maybe they want
him to warn people that the walkers are
combing the walkers are intelligent they
have a deal with Craster where he gives
them babies to be turned into white
walkers and there are hints of ancient
cooperation between walkers and the
Nights Watch was there some agreement
between humans and the walkers a
connection between House Stark and the
night King how am I this relate to the
wall the worlds irregular seasons and
the legendary hero azor Ahai the show's
creators said there are three holy [ __ ]
moments in Game of Thrones the sacrifice
of Shireen the origin of Hodor and one
more shock at the end maybe we'll learn
the true nature and motivations of the
White Walkers also if you want to get
tinfoil this symbol of a line through a
circle appears all through the series it
kind of looks like this badge that the
walkers wear and if you zoom in some
more it's probably nothing in the next
scene we meet the Starks of Winterfell
the loving parents Catelyn and Ned the
adventurous bran bastard Jon and fur
born Rob ladylike Sansa tomboy ayah and
young Rickon they're a happy family
before all the tragedies that come the
fall of bran death of Ned and burning of
Winterfell the red wedding abuse of
Sansa indoctrination of aya the death of
John and death of Rick on this family
suffers so much and while they can
rebuild they'll never get back what they
at once had even now things aren't
perfect Catelyn resents John because
John is Ned's bastard a living reminder
of her husband's infidelity except now
we know that John actually isn't Ned's
bastard John is the son of Ned sister
Lyanna with Rhaegar Targaryen Ned says
John is his to protect John from King
Robert who would kill John if he knew he
was Targaryen so for all these years
Ned lies to his beloved wife Kat to keep
his promise to Liana
he can see the pain that this causes to
Ned and Kat and John
there's also tension with Arya who
doesn't fit the gender role she's
expected to play and Theon Greyjoy's an
outsider as award from the Iron Islands
he stands here with Roderick who Theon
later kills when he attacks Winterfell
the Theon John and aya all feel like
they don't fit in and that drives them
to find new identities Theon with the
Greyjoy's John with the Nights Watch and
Arya with the faceless men
the Starks capture will The Watchmen who
survived the start of the episode he
says he saw White Walkers but no one
believes him maybe if someone listened
and investigated this whole story would
have gone differently but the penalty
for leaving the watch is death so will
is executed Ned kills will himself
because he believes that the man who
passes the sentence should swing the
sword Rob and John later follow Ned's
example even Theon does the same with
Roderick because Ned represents honor
and justice and personal responsibility
he can say that these values are what
lead to Ned's death but Ned's legacy
lives on in how stark compared Ned to
Tywin
Lannister he's obsessed with family
legacy and his brutality and treachery
make the Lannisters powerful but after
he dies his house collapses his children
turn on each other and all his grandkids
die Tywin's brutal legacy fails but
Ned's survives because he's a leader who
people truly believe in after the
execution the Starks find a dead
direwolf and a dead stack foreshadowing
the deaths of Ned and Robert whose
sigils are a direwolf and a stag but the
dead dire wolf has six pups one for each
stark kid
direwolves mystical creatures
symbolizing special destinies for the
Starks especially for bran who learns to
walk his wolf and for John with his
albino wolf so this is about the dying
of an older generation and the rise of a
new generation like the passing of the
seasons down in King's Landing we meet
Cersei and Jaime Lannister Jaime is a
careless arrogant prince charming so
different to the responsible humbolt
Jaime of later seasons but early so
she's not so different she has all the
ambition and resentment that leads to a
tyranny later wrong go watch out Cersei
and Jaime videos for more were also
introduced to Tyrion the lecherous imp
he's a more lighthearted character
before all his suffering later on
there's also much more sex and nudity in
the early seasons of Thrones Season 7
barely has any maybe because of
criticism from the media we meet the
prostitute Rose who has a long arc in
the show she moves to King's Landing
works for Littlefinger and Varys and
gives us the perspective of a common
person among the nobility Rose moves up
in the world and climbs her way out of
sex work but Littlefinger finds out that
she's spying on him and gives her to
Joffrey so Rose becomes another victim
of the game of Thrones
back at Winterfell were introduced to
another important character Jon Snow's
ABS these ABS go through some complex
character development too much to cover
in this video
King Robert Baratheon arrives and he
greets each of the Starks differently he
touches Ned Catelyn robb and Rickon and
all of these characters die while the
Starks he doesn't touch are still alive
Robert asks iya who what her name is
just like the faceless men asked iya who
what her name is when she's trained to
be no one Robert tells bran he'll be a
soldier Bran's injury ends his dream of
being a knight but you can say he's now
a soldier in the war against the White
Walkers we see bran climbing and it's
tragic how happy he is running and
jumping before he's paralyzed man before
he loses his personality as the
emotionless three-eyed Raven while
climbing bran sees the world from above
just like he later use Ravens to
magically see the world from above his
whole power as a three-eyed Raven is to
see things and this episode bran sees a
lot he says we'll get killed said Cersei
and Jaime make babies bran says he sees
the king coming just like he later sees
the night king coming so there's a lot
of foreshadowing happening in this
episode Robert and Ned visit the
Winterfell crypts and talk about Liana
Ned's sister who Robert loved Robert
still hates the Targaryen spur taking
Leanna Ned says the Targaryen czar gone
but Robert says not all of them he's
talking about Daenerys and Viserys
Targaryen but this can also refer to
John aka Aegon Targaryen
so again Ned his keeping secrets from
his friend Robert over in the east we
meet the Targaryen Daenerys and Viserys
Dany is make and afraid worn down by
abuse from her brother
sure runner David Benioff said Danny is
little more than a slave this episode
may be this experience as a slave is
what leads Danny to fight against
slavery in later seasons
Daenerys takes a buff and her maid warns
that it's too hot but Danny isn't hurt
this foreshadows the later revealed that
Dany can't be burned by fire in the
books Dany can be burned
the thing with Drago's pyre is a one-off
mirakl that either way of being the
unburnt connects Danny to the magic of
fire and Dragons and perhaps to a
destiny as azor Ahai the hero prophesied
to defeat the White Walkers
the Targaryen czar hosted by Illyrio
mopatis peep soon disappears from the
show but in the books he's a much bigger
character he and Varys have a complex
conspiracy to put a different Targaryen
on the throne but the plan now is to use
a Dothraki army to invade Westeros
so tenaris is married to Carl Drago
Illyrio gives Danny dragon eggs and the
new Targaryen history book reveals where
these eggs may have come from we'll
cover this in a new video so subscribe
and press the bell
Daenerys looks longingly at the sunset
like Luke Skywalker a hero dreaming of
something greater in life but then Drogo
rapes Daenerys in the books the sex is
more consensual Drogo asks permission
and Danny says yes she gets some agency
and control of her life but in the show
Danny's growth from a slave to a queen
is yet to begin back at Winterfell
there's an extra playing Jane Poole who
has one of the saddest stories in the
books
Jane is Sansa's friend and is excited to
come to King's Landing but her father is
killed by Lannisters and Jane's given to
Littlefinger who uses her in his brothel
jane is then forced to pretend to be
arya and to marry ramsay who abuses her
horrific leigh she escapes loses part of
her face to frostbite and heads to the
wall some speculate she'll continue to
Braavos and commit suicide at the house
of black and white
Sansa's innocent young friend suffers as
much as anyone in Game of Thrones
while the Starks hosts have faced John
stays outside because it might insult
the royal family to seat a bastard in
their midst
ironically John isn't a bastard as a
Targaryen he's royalty and Joffrey in
the face isn't actually royalty he's the
bastard of Cersei and Jaime John speaks
with Uncle Ben
and John says he wants to join the
Nights Watch but benjin warns him that
had mean not having a family and not
fathering sons and John might care about
that if he knew what it meant
some fans speculated that benjin knows
that John is a Targaryen because John
joining the watch would mean giving up
his claim to the throne except John may
have got out of his vows by dying then
being reborn we get a moment with
Catelyn and Sansa and see Sansa's naive
dreams of marrying Joffrey and being his
queen Sansa zark is all about her losing
those illusions Catelyn is a woman
defined by her love for her children and
this episode she starts to lose them
Cersei says a beauty like Sansa
shouldn't stay hidden in the north
forever and it scares Kat to see the
scheming Cersei taking her daughter away
and rightly so because after this
episode can't never cease Sansa again
Jon meets Tyrion who says never forget
what you are wear it like armor so it
can't be used to hurt you this means to
be yourself openly and proudly to
embrace your identity as a dwarf or a
bastard so that no one can use it
against you except this really doesn't
work for Tyrion in season 4 he's
sentenced to death largely because
people believe his reputation as a
conniving lecherous imp may be wearing
your identity like armor doesn't
actually work cat gets a letter from her
sister Lisa saying that the Lannisters
killed her husband Jon Arryn but in
season 4 we find out it was actually
Lysa who killed Jon under the orders of
little finger little finger caused
conflict between the Starks and
Lannisters for his own agenda bringing
war death and horror on the Starks it's
only in season 7 that little fingers
finally brought to justice for these
crimes bran sees socie and Jaime's
twincest so Jaime pushes him from a
tower starred in brands arc as a psychic
tree boy and Jaime's long road to
redemption but what will happen if bran
and Jaime meet again will Jamie make
amends for breaking an innocent boy will
Brown even care now that he's become the
three-eyed Raven
whatever happens brands fall from this
tower represents change the passing of
the Starks and the return of the
Targaryen and the end of summer for
winter is coming so season 1 episode 1
introduces the Starks Targaryen slan
Astor's and White Walkers these are the
same factions left by the final season
the Baratheon's Tyrells Martel's and
Greyjoy's are all cool but they mostly
just come then go they're not central to
the story like these guys it looks like
the final season of Game of Thrones will
end the way it began with fire and to
ice and incestuous blonde people season
8 is coming in April so now's a good
time to read The Game of Thrones books
as well as the main series there are the
dunk and egg prequels the World Book and
the new fire and blood history book
audible is offering three months of
membership for 695 a month at
audible.com slash ASX each month gets
you a free audiobook so you could get
the first three Thrones books or all of
these spin-off books for cheaper than
that cost on paper you can listen in the
car or the gym or in a really hot bath
sign up at audible.com slash ASX
or text asx2 500 500 thanks for watching
comment below if you want more videos on
early episodes please like and subscribe
and thanks to patrons Debby scow
Catherine Suarez Elaine Woodling Anthony
Board Annette Tom Gabby ash Stoker and
fab R Cheers
you